hey man I'm doing 50 Grand a month I
think I've saturated my market I'm like
it's a 60 billion dollar industry well I
can't grow past year I'm like okay
you're just blaming the circumstance on
the fact that you have an ignorance or a
lack of skills to get over this hump
which is like you have one sales guy
maybe you should hire another one oh no
we just doubled the business what a
concept it's like you didn't saturate
the market this is crazy but most people
just do the next thing rather than
fixing the problem in front of them and
then when they add up all their income
streams it's still the same number and
that's what's really interesting is that
I think that those like entrepreneurs
have a certain like income level or
Revenue level that they can support with
their skill set and it just divides out
between whatever amount of things you
have but the thing is once it's divided
out I don't think you can move forward
until you figure out how to overcome
which usually means you have to focus on
one figure out the problem is and then
all of a sudden you get the next level